[Music]
[Applause]
we are getting i guess
sort of maybe somehow closer to the
infrastructure
reform plan that joe biden has proposed
and republican leaders met yesterday
with joe biden
and they said we will draw a line in the
sand when it comes to raising taxes to
pay for infrastructure
they will not accept it and my reaction
is
i don't think they were ever going to
vote for this anyway so does it even
really
make a difference and ultimately pat i
think this is just going to come down to
where democrats ready to pass this
themselves with no republican support in
order to do that you need joe manchin
you need kirsten cinema i know
uh but it's almost like these you know
it's sort of like with the stimulus
package where
biden wanted 1.9 trillion or 2 trillion
and republicans wanted 600 billion but
even if you negotiated to some point in
the middle
they still weren't going to vote for it
and ultimately they didn't it was just
democrats i don't even know
why joe biden is doing this other than
for the optics of saying i did talk to
them but they were very unreasonable
i think it's all about optics here i
understand that republicans are
not going to come to the table with any
serious offer
and they're not going to work with
democrats and joe biden to pass
infrastructure
but everyone has to play their role here
everyone has to play some politics and i
think
biden paying lip service to republicans
is good right
you know it gives the impression that
he's trying to reach out to the other
side
and also i think what it does is it
allows for joe manchin and kirsten
cinema to
join with the democrats in passing this
on their own because
at least with this you can make it look
as though biden tried to reach out to
the other side
and that could provide just enough cover
for mansion and cinema to
vote for the infrastructure deal and
that's all you need you just need the
democrats so long as you can hold those
down
then you get it passed i hope that's
what he's doing here i read a funny line
from mitch mcconnell which is just like
so emblematic of what actually mitch
mcconnell sometimes does really well uh
mcconnell said during a press uh
availability
we're not interested in reopening the
2017 tax bill
like that's our red line and it's like
that's politics
and what mitch mcconnell has this
ability to do and sometimes it works pat
is he'll act like listen we'll do
politics in good faith
but like we're not going back and
revising x that's now just the way
things work
as if like now the 2017 tax reform bill
that's just that's taxes we can never
change that again because that's now set
in stone
and yet with obamacare they were never
able they never
were willing to accept like okay listen
let's build on obamacare
not just go back and try to vote it out
but it's like no they voted 63 or
whatever number of times they were
i have to give them credit they actually
do pull this stuff off with a straight
face like no it wouldn't be legitimate
to rethink the tax bill because we
already decided on taxes in 2017
as if that's not a constant conversation
in the american political space
yeah tax rates can change and they do
change over time
but mitch mcconnell here is trying to
defend his corporate donors and the
people who put him in power to begin
with who
benefited quite handsomely off of that
2017 tax cut bill
and what is he really saying by saying
that it's a red line
because that just means that democrats
would have to pass their infrastructure
package
by raising the deficit in spending
without having enough funds coming in to
pay for it right away right
whereas you could also alternatively
come up with a system where you raise
taxes on the rich and raise the
corporate taxes and the capital gains
taxes to pay for these infrastructure
plans
and out of those two options either
raising the deficit or having the rich
pay for it
i mean i would probably rather have
increased taxes on the rich to pay for
it it could be a combination of those
two things of course because we know
that deficit spending can be good if
it's for the right reasons
but what would republicans say you know
given that you're going to have this
infrastructure bill how would you want
it to be paid for
i'd be interested in what they'd have to
say yeah or would you rather it be paid
for it all
or would you prefer to just allow it to
pass without any of your support and no
way to pay for it other than deficit
spending
and then complain about that and it may
be that latter thing they may just
prefer to say
look at what they did we didn't support
it we couldn't afford it there was no
money and now
you know that's the question now what
because it's not clear that it will
actually be bad for the economy
i don't know what their endgame is but
it seems that obstruction is a big part
of it
the other thing regarding this red line
with the 2017 tax cut bill
maybe maybe that just has to do with the
fact that that was really trump's only
significant legislative accomplishment
and so if biden and democrats undo that
or
make changes to the tax code then what
are republicans going to run on in the
future when they're trying to
elect future republican presidents they
can't point to that tax cut bill
they'll nothing returning obamacare yeah
there's really nothing left
legislatively and so maybe that's why
they're also holding on to this
that's a possibility yeah so we'll see
what happens but they've drawn a red
line
ladies and gentlemen very very important
uh this is super interesting
a couple of months ago elon musk
announced that tesla
uh the electric car manufacturer has
been accumulating
uh stores of bitcoin and will start
accepting bitcoin for payment
and when this happened for vehicles and
when this happened the
price of bitcoin went way up last night
elon musk tweeted
we are no longer going to accept uh
bitcoin for cars
we're keeping all the bitcoin we have we
haven't sold it but we're not going to
be accepting payment anymore
because of the energy usage
of bitcoin which is a much debated topic
um and only if bitcoin solves the energy
usage
or he would also look at a different
cryptocurrency that doesn't have the
energy issues
will they go back to accepting
cryptocurrency for payment this
collapsed the price of bitcoin
although it has already recovered
probably about a third of the initial
price collapse as of right now
do you think that this is anything other
than elon musk shrewdly manipulating the
bitcoin markets like that's the cynical
interpretation of this
or do you think that this is like
because the the stuff about bitcoin
energy use
was known a decade ago how did he not
know it two months ago
that's the thing that's why i'm cynical
about this too because you're right when
tesla announced that they would accept
payment with bitcoin uh whenever that
was just a few months ago or whatever
they knew about the
energy costs and you know how it takes a
lot of energy to mine bitcoin
nothing has changed on that front no uh
so i do wonder if maybe he is trying to
manipulate the price of cryptocurrency
of course he's done it with bitcoin he's
also done it with dogecoin
uh you know he's promoted it and also
when he went on snl last week
uh a lot of people were expecting him to
promote dogecoin i don't think he
actually did that and the price ended up
falling but
you know he has this control over these
crypto markets and when he's saying
something like oh we're going to look
for
another cryptocurrency that doesn't use
nearly as much energy
that makes me think okay well he's just
trying to pump up the next one
and maybe some people can get rich off
of that i don't know which crypto he's
going to pick
the thing about that is he's so wealthy
i can't imagine that
if this is what he's doing he's doing it
for money it's gotta be for fun
right yeah it could just be like a power
play right like he already has
plenty of money he doesn't need any more
of it but i mean
it must be some sort of like power high
that he gets
off of the ability to control markets
like this i mean even before
he was doing it with cryptocurrency he
was doing it with the regular stock
market right like he would say something
and
tesla's stock would shoot through the
roof or it would go down yeah i think he
loves this stuff and he certainly hates
the sec
that may be and like every aspect of
this is always
up for debate like there's no question
that there's a high energy usage for the
mining of bitcoin
but the uh one you know bitcoin has a
limited
like i'm just giving the devil's
advocate sort of like every side thing
on the one hand there's a huge energy uh
uh consumption for the mining of bitcoin
at the same time bitcoin has a limit of
21 million coins and when that's reached
there's not going to be any more mining
as far as i understand and then it's
just
the transactions which are not
particularly um
resource intensive and then there's the
counterpoint that well
a lot of the mining is happening with
renewable surplus energy anyway so it's
not really using fossil fuels but then
the counter to that is well actually
the study that claimed that was funded
by mining companies so it's not an
honest study
i don't know but what i do know is that
this is unlikely to be a cycle that ends
anytime soon and
what will be the next thing that bumps
up the price and who will profit from
that i have no idea
right i mean it could be another company
announcing that they're going to start
accepting bitcoin as payment but i don't
think anyone can move markets like elon
musk can
no i mean maybe donald trump when he was
president he would tweet something crazy
uh but when it comes to deliberately
manipulating markets i don't think
there's someone else
who really has that sort of control
because there's a cult of personality
behind
elon musk that i don't think exists with
other people i completely agree
and we'll see i don't think we'll ever
ever really know his motivations but we
will we will keep an eye on it
um one of the things that i guess we've
learned although we probably already
suspected it for
quite a period of time through what's
been going on with the vaccination
campaigns for the coronavirus pandemic
is that there is a lack of trust
in many public health institutions and
there is now
new data from the robert wood johnson
foundation and harvard school of public
health which finds
that the most trusted public health
group
is the cdc and only 52 percent of
americans trusted a great deal
followed by local health departments at
44
trust state health departments at 41
significant trust the surgeon general at
40 percent
the nih which is fouchy's organization
but
the organization which fouchy heads it's
not his organization
at 37 percent the fda at 37 percent
and the u.s department of health and
human services at 33 percent
these numbers are very very low and to
some degree
i understand skepticism of government
because government
so often lies and says things that
aren't true
but in this context pat i don't
understand
the numbers being so low for example for
like a local health department what
incentive does a local
health department have to either lie or
deceive
and what track record do they have where
we would say wow they really can't be
trusted
right like does the average person know
what their local health department even
does i suppose that the average person
could say that their local health
department is just a
puppet organization of the cdc or these
broader organizations that they don't
trust but
uh yeah this really isn't surprising
especially a year after a pandemic when
the cdc and the nih and these other
institutions have been in such focus i
mean
of course there are going to be a
portion of americans who are opposed to
them by now
but i wonder if like a lot of this just
tracks to
the decision made early on by the cdc
not to recommend
wearing masks it took them until i think
it was april 3rd 2020 to
change their minds on the masks and
maybe that created a bunch of skepticism
with people
that never got undone i don't think
really that skepticism is deserved
because yes the cdc made an
initial mistake when it came to masks or
maybe they were just trying to save them
for the healthcare workers and the
people who most needed them whatever the
case may be
but a lot of these people who don't
trust the cdc trust figures like trump
who were also dead wrong about the virus
who claimed that
the cases would go from 15 to zero yeah
and you know someone in trump who didn't
wear a mask and promoted things like
hydroxychloroquine and bleach and all
this stuff
all of that was wrong and hypocritical
and all that stuff too uh but for
whatever reason a lot of these people
who are skeptical about the cdc don't
call out right-wing politicians when
they get this stuff wrong
now is that is that really the date
april 3rd that they swit they changed
their view on masks
i'm pretty sure april 3rd is the day
where they started to recommend that the
public wear masks
what's insane about that is it's still a
talking point
that for they made this major mistake on
masks
trump didn't even address the country
about the pandemic until it was either
march 12th
or march 15th within two to three weeks
they already found the right position on
masks it's now been 13 months
and we're still seeing republicans go
back to that and say
if if it was that quick that's also a
really
short turnaround to come to the right
position yeah and if my memory serves me
correctly the one who made the
announcement about the cdc recommending
masks
was donald trump himself and he just
right away undercut that message by
saying well i'm not gonna wear one
myself i don't know if you remember that
yeah but yeah there really was that one
mistake but that was a long time ago and
i think a lot of people blow it out of
proportion to
act as if well one month they say that
masks are okay the next month they say
don't wear them and then
after that they say wear them again
there's not this constant flip-flopping
there was one change
and it happened over a year ago at this
point i think we can move on i think we
know why they
made that mistake it was also a novel
virus and we didn't know too much about
it at the time
um and so you know it's totally fine to
sort of like dig into
why they didn't recommend masks earlier
uh you know whether or not they could
have promoted uh
people making cloth masks at home so you
wouldn't have to worry about medical
masks not being available and all this
stuff it's fine to criticize all that
but
just to to not trust the cdc and these
other health organizations just because
of that one mistake doesn't make any
sense to me
uh the other aspect of this is people do
seem to trust
their personal doctors their local
doctors in their communities
so one of the reactions to this poll has
been well
maybe we make an effort to get people
information
through local doctors the problem is
most people aren't in touch with their
local doctor particularly frequently
unless they need something
and also a lot of the doctors are
politically a question mark i mean it's
not it's people trust their local
doctors but it's not like
all local doctors personal doctors pcps
are on board with what are the
prevailing messages from some of these
health organizations so this seems like
a major problem i don't really know how
you fix it
yeah i mean hopefully we can leverage
that to our advantage i remember biden
was
asked about uh vaccine skepticism
and skepticism generally about how
severe covet is
yeah and he mentioned that one of the
things that people can do to reassure
themselves
that this is a serious problem and that
you should get vaccinated is to speak to
your
your own doctor because people trust
their own doctor even more so than
politicians
um that's for sure and so i think that's
a good piece of advice but if you only
see your doctor once a year for a
primary care visit
and that time of year may not even
overlap with right now when it's time
for people to start getting the vaccines
then yeah it doesn't really help you all
that much no question yeah and this is a
bigger issue
about you know we've talked before about
how
healthy skepticism of how you come to
learn things
and what you trust and who you trust
that's good
where you get into the conspiracism is
this unending
skepticism that can never be satisfied
and where evidence or the absence of
evidence
either way points to the same conspiracy
that's where this gets very
ugly and it doesn't seem like we're
finding finding the balance in the
united states
and i think a lot of people just like to
be contrarians right like early on when
masks weren't really in focus there were
some on the right who started hoarding
masks and wearing them and then once
the cdc started recommending mask usage
and most people started wearing them
then these same contrarians stopped
wearing them and all of a sudden stopped
thinking that they were important and
you can find that with many many
different issues and i wish there was
like some way of
sort of using reverse psychology or
whatever to uh
to affect change to make people more on
board with going along with these public
health measures
and reality in general but i don't think
you can really do that i don't think
that works
i don't think it does and i think it has
significant risks i mean that
at an individual level reverse
psychology can be something to try
i think you know at some kind of
national level it would be
extremely risky and no no serious public
health organization would try it
um all right we're going to follow i
mean listen now with 12 to 15 year olds
being able to get vaccinated i'm curious
to see what vaccination numbers look
like early and and towards the end of
next week as vaccination starts for 12
to 15 year olds
let's see what the numbers look like
let's see what happens and we're going
to sort of go from there but certainly
some concerning numbers as far as trust
and public health
that does it for today we'll be back
tomorrow new show new bonus show maybe
even a live stream